لطالما تصدرت ايران قائمه دول العالم من
حيث حالات الاعدام لكن العام 2022 جاء
استثنائيا
فتنفيذ احكام الاعدام ارتفع بحسب منظمه
هارانا بنسبه 88% هذا العام مقارنه بالعام
الماضي عدد من صدرت او نفذ ضدهم احكام
بالاعدام في ايران خلال هذا العام بلغ
565 شخصا من بينهم 11 امراه وخمسه مدانيين
تقل اعمارهم عن 18 عاما اي يعتبرون اطفال
بحسب القانون الدولي
الاسباب متعددت فمن ادانات بجرائم
المخدرات الى اتهامات بالتعاون مع اسرائيل
ومؤخرا بدا القضاء الايراني في اصدار
احكام بالاعدام في حق المشاركين في
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه بهدف ترهيب المحتجين
بعد ان فشلت اجراءات النظام الاخرى مثل
حال شرطه الاخلاق في انهاء التظاهرات
مؤسسه رانيا التي اصدرت التقرير عن
الاعدامات تتهم النظام باستخدام الاعدام
التعسفي سلاحا في وجه معارضيه ولا فتاه
الى ترتيب المحافظات والمدن الايرانيه من
حيث نسب الاعدام هذه النسب بحسب المنظمات
تظهر سعي طهران الاستهداف حقوق الاقليات
الدينيه والمذهبيه والقوميه تقريره رانا
كشف ان 18 ونصف في المئه من الاعدامات في
عام 2022 تمت في محافظه بلوشستان ذات
الاغلبيه السنيه
باكثر من 16% كما ان اكثر حالات الاعدام
كانت في سجن زهدان ورجائي شهر الاعدامات
التعسفيه في ايران اثاره انتقادات قويه من
منظمات حقوقيه دوليه شككت في مصداقيه
احكام الاعدام التي يصدرها القضاء
الايراني وخاصه ضد المحتجين الذين فشلت
محاولات النظام في اخماد تظاهراتهم حتى
الان
[موسيقى]